We have a pretty epic
water crisis in Mexico City.
And so we figured,
let's start harvesting
rainwater in these neighborhoods
where people need it.
Isla Urbana is an organization
that designs and installs
rainwater harvesting systems.
We've installed
something like 24,000
or 25,000 rainwater
harvesting systems
just using revenue.
We once spent 25 days
without any water.
Only in the nighttime
we get some water,
Friday or Saturday.
It looks yellow, it smells.
We have to buy drinking water.
I tell my wife, this will be
The rainwater harvesting
systems that we install
are pretty simple.
It teaches people
how to harvest, filter,
and potabilize water at home.
The whole thing starts with
the roof of the house,
which is the catchment surface.
So we work with the family
so that they have a very clear
understanding of keeping
the roof as clean as possible.
The water that falls
off of that roof,
we channel through
gutters and pipes.
We chlorinate that water.
We do a simple
sedimentation process
that allows fine
particles of sediments
to settle in the tank.
And then after that,
we pass it through
a pretty simple filtration system
that then feeds water
to the rest of the house.
And we can get water of
whatever quality we need.
From kind of general use domestic water,
we can get purified
water that you could bottle.
We prepare the roof when
the rainy season is near,
and there we collect the rain.
It is useful for many things,
and it is very clean.
We harvest from 15,000 to
20,000 liters of water per year.
Ten people occupy that water.
We spend the whole
year with that water.
It is enough, thankfully.
When the rainy
season was over,
we would only have
800 liters of water left,
and we had to make it
last three or four months.
Now with this rainwater harvesting system,
we can capture
3,000 liters of rainwater.
It has certain filters that
make the water better quality.
Harvesting rainwater,
it's an ancient practice
that people have done forever
and kind of largely abandoned
as we kind of
adopted other ideas
of how we should get water
and what modern water
access should look like.
But in that pursuit,
there's all of these
that just kind of fell through
the cracks and were left in these
continuously
precarious situations,
living with often very, very
small amounts of water,
often with water
very poor quality,
often paying an
enormous amount
proportional to their
income, getting water.
Well, the scarcity has
been going on for years.
We no longer receive water daily.
It recently failed us
for like 15 days.
We had to buy a pipe,
it cost us 700 pesos.
They were increasingly
limiting our water service.
The water from the faucet,
well, it's not that bad,
but it has leaves, dirt, bacteria.
It's no longer good for drinking.
We have spent 25 days without water.
Mexico City is one
of the top 10 cities
rated most likely to
run out of water
in the world by
The Nature Conservancy.
We've done a lot of work
getting policy passed.
Mexico now has requirements for
rainwater harvesting systems
to be integrated into
new construction.
Very fundamentally,
we need to start
being able to use the
water that we have
and reduce the amount of water
that we need to pull
out of the ground.
And the most direct and simplest
way to do that is to start actually
using the rainwater
that falls on us.
Many years ago there
was a lot of water.
There were many
ditches of clean water.
A lot of water would come
out from the subsoil.
Here one would scratch
a meter, or half a meter
and the water came out.
In 1970 there was
still plenty of water.
The urban sprawl grew
and everything collapsed.
It's all gone.
I would trace
the story of Mexico City's
water crisis to an event
that happened in 1607
when the viceroy of New Spain,
based out of Mexico City,
decided that Mexico City
was going to be a
dryland city like Madrid
and made the decision to drain
the lake of Texcoco.
As the city was built on
this old lake bed,
the soft ground underneath
would sink and the result of
channelling all of the rain
out of the city as quickly
as possible to avoid flooding
has also stopped the process
of recharging the groundwater.
And that's kind of the core of
the water crisis in Mexico City.
Always saving water,
always saving.
We must know how to
save our water because
what will it be for
our future generations?
What are they going to do?
We are living through this now.
In the future, it will
be even worse.
We need more because
we are more in the planet,
yet the amount of
water stays the same.
We've gotten this deeply
intimate vision into how people
are experiencing the water
crisis and I think
it's something that will
end up being relevant
to many, many cities
throughout the world,
what's being developed
here in Mexico City.